alcohol used to be this social thing I
used to connect with people and go out
had now become something I did nightly
alone by myself I woke up with the worst
hangover and for the first time ever I
had this voice in my head that said this
is not okay those situations created
such a deep level of Shame inside of me
that I wasn't able to shake alcohol in
the wake of those experiences and I just
like held on to that belief that real
Lucy came out when she was drinking up
until I gave it up alcohol played a
major role in my life I started drinking
young people who drink every day have
smaller brains I was drinking just
trying to take the pain away I actually
didn't know who I was until very
recently alcohol is not a health food I
kind of thought to myself that if I can
give up Alcove for a whole year that
proves I'm in control I will be able to
go back to it and this won't happen
again but obviously that's not the case